are there any any other places outside
of tokyo that's the obvious count
oh yeah are we going to talk about kyoto
what is it like cancelled
i don't know if we can mention it
i think kyoto is still great to go if
you're you're going to go to osaka right
because it's a fun place yeah and you
may you might want to go to usj see the
mario world yeah you may as well go to
kyoto it's it's an hour away 40 minutes
i think right no it's like super duper
30 minutes yeah you may as well go to
both uh kyoto is a [ __ ] nightmare to
get around though i will say uh i know
there's ways you can get around with
public transport but honestly if you're
going there for a trip i'd say just just
taxi it around to kyoto it's super easy
it's a lot cheaper to get a taxi in
kyoto and you can do way more [ __ ]
because if you just taxi from places in
kyoto you'll get so much more done
i know that me and chris had like so
many like major
like tourist things in that one day yeah
just because we just taxied everywhere
yeah
yeah and uh the ryokans in kyoto are
amazing obviously super traditional if
you want that like super traditional
japan
[Music]
like all those and then the good thing
is again osaka is only 30 minutes away
nara where you can feed the deers is
only like 45 minutes away you can go to
the other side you can go to shiga which
is near like uh biwako which is japan's
biggest inland lake that place is really
lovely churchill feels like underrated
iphone store of japan
so everything is so minimal and clean
yeah kyoto is so
impeccable how do you think it's going
to be when the country opens up and we
get tourists i'm scared i've only ever
been to kyoto with no tourists yeah
because i've been to kyoto with tourists
and it's hell because like the reason i
was just like do we want to talk about
kyoto it's just because like i mean yeah
i mean like people people will want to
go obviously but it is
even more probably like when tourists
when the country opens back up it's
going to be even more of a tourist trap
than tokyo is
i think that's what it seems like
it's extremely popular with chinese
tourists yeah this is uh there's a lot
of historically i went during chinese
new year and it was oh my god oh my god
it was like literal shoulder to shoulder
well i didn't want to eat today anyway
all the stores are full
yeah because like kyoto yeah it's a cool
place it's not like the place that i
it's not my vibe when it comes to travel
just because it's like it's going to be
so busy so packed and you're going to be
lining up for like uh for like the
[ __ ] 10th temple that you've seen
that day or something like that and i'm
just like you know what maybe like maybe
we can skip this temple i just i i i go
somewhere i just want some nice i get it
it's not for everyone but i love it a
lot of people love it um yeah like i
recommend the places around kyoto more
than kyoto itself kyoto is like a good
base hub i've been together a few times
in the past two years i've gotta say my
enjoyment of kyoto depended on the
weather
right kyoto gets so hot it does i'm in
the summer it's unbearable yeah i just i
wouldn't even bother going to oh my god
in summer i just i genuinely i tell
people i'm like just don't don't come in
august you're not gonna have fun yeah
just come between
october just come just come just come
come right now come 301 come uh come
between october and
april
i i have the first time i i would mostly
agree with you except of the existence
of okinawa okay if you're going to occur
but how many people are going to get
okinawa like not that many a lot of
people okay
here's here's here's the thing because
that's where i recommend tokyo sucks in
the summer yeah i i i will fully agree
with connor because if you're going to
go to japan to go to just okinawa then
[ __ ] go to southeast asian countries
like there's so many [ __ ] beaches
there you know okinawa is where
we go when we live in japan because we
don't have [ __ ] off our we colonized
this island bizarre
yeah i mean okinawa is where
is uh
is where we go if you live in japan to
get to like a good beach because there's
not many choices when it comes to good
beaches here in japan unfortunately god
forbid mainland japan is a good beach
yeah because i'm in like shimoda and
stuff
i mean
it has a bunch i don't know my my
standard of beaches is very high yeah oh
yeah yeah so i don't know and i feel
okinawa is the only place that fits my
australian standard yeah
i was raised in like some of the best
beaches in the world
yeah japan doesn't have a lot of choices
when it comes to beaches uh funny for an
island nation but then again i'm from
england as well and we have the exact
same problem so
but i would argue that okinawa is not
only great for the beaches but you know
kind of very similar to hokkaido where
like the food that you can get in
okinawa is like next level i've never
actually been to okinawa yes
but i've only seen like the spam sushi
you know like spam sushi's like you know
more famous one but like there's so many
there's so many like traditionalist
okinawan yuki style foods that are just
so good and i mean like the booze in
okinawa as well like you know because
like in in a hokkaido you have sapporo
bee yeah right which is like you drink
sapporobi in hokkaido it's like poor
classic support which you can only get
in like hokkaido for some reason yeah
whereas in okinawa there's a specific
type of beer called an orion bee or an
orion b however you want to pronounce it
and orion b in sapporo
in okinawa is probably just as nut
worthy as a sapporo in hokkaido in my
life well you said onion beer
and then you cut the onion cut the onion
it's like a okinawa specific beer and
that on like a summer day in okinawa is
you okay it's so good and just okinawan
food in general if you want like a
different kind of twist on japanese food
that you can't really get anywhere else
i would definitely recommend okinawan
food yeah and there's plenty of okinawa
based restaurants in tokyo as well like
there's there's a really good one in
nikki booker actually in sunshine city i
go to quite a bit
um so if you want like a different take
on japanese food
i recommend knocking on food